so if you're headed to the snow are you
prepared even just for the drive up to
the mountain right Candace Charles
joining us live from the bottom of Mount
Charleston and Kyle Canyon with the
things that you need this is all just in
case Candace you always want to make
sure you're prepared
that is absolutely right Heather good
morning to good morning folks you can
already see the mountain in the back
here it's really Frosty some snow over
there and take a look at this you guys
this really explains how busy Mount
Charleston fire department is this is
their toe straps they use this to get
vehicles they've gone up there a lot to
get them so in order to have the items
you need to wait out for them to come to
get you you want a few items in your
truck your truck in your truck and I'm
joined by fire chief Jorge Gonzalez
thank you so much for joining us tell us
about the items we have here so so some
of the items that we have uh uh for uh
helping people or shovels snow shovel an
ice scraper a uh a tire repair
dedicated a flashlight making sure you
have water food in your vehicle a jumper
or cables to jump your vehicle in case
you need emergency uh jump and when you
do go up there to rescue folks what are
some of the main issues that they've run
into and do they have any of these items
usually yeah most of the visitors are
unaware of the winter driving conditions
up in the mountain so first of all make
sure you're well informed about the road
conditions the weather conditions and be
prepared for the uh the extreme weather
conditions up in the mountain all right
and these things could also be used for
extreme heat as well right correct some
of the items definitely recommend having
a new vehicle at all times whether it's
winter or summer driving conditions all
right thank you so much fire to
Godzillas for all that you do as well I
appreciate you being out here this
morning we got you covered with a list
of things you will need to have in your
car for any emergency honor website
angelsnow.com check with indot before
going up up here on the roads have your
entire chains ready and assembled
correctly and of course have one 511 on
dial in case you have an emergency or
need any assistance for now live from uh
Kyle Kenny I'm Candace Charles a news
now